the night is perhaps the most fun piece
and chess it is the only piece and chest
that does not move in some sort of
straight line it moves in a strange L
shape the other interesting thing about
the night is it's the only piece and
chess that can jump over other pieces
like this it takes a little practice to
understand exactly how the night moves
it goes two squares in one direction and
then one square to the side like this
highlighted are all the possible squares
the night can move to on the next turn
notice that always moves in the same
pattern - to the side in over one like
this or like this up to an over one or
down 2 and over 1 and notice that the
night moves from a light Square to a
dark Square and then on the next turn it
moves from a dark Square to a light
Square the night always switches colors
with each turn it makes now that you've
learned how the night moves it's your
turn to practice moving this fun and
tricky piece